okay glooty take the app down kind of
take it down it's your app I'm just an
antenna
that's not how apps work you think we're
stupid but we're not we know apps have
something to do with servers the service
on the mothership where's the mothership
it's coming take us to it yes shake it
more Morty that was working take us to
the mothership okay okay don't hit an
ominous beeping app you can't stay mad
at a guy with this kind of talent dad
you can
[Music]
[Applause]
we're just finishing season 4 while
we're starting season 5 and we've got hi
everyone happy comic-con we got our
first trailer for Rick and Morty season
4 so we got to break it down you
probably recognize the voice from that
so they announced a whole bunch of stuff
and details for what's going on with the
episodes and what's gonna be happening
with future seasons will do a new Rick
and Morty merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Rick and Morty moment on
the video so just starting with the clip
then I'll address what they said about
future seasons the clip is actually
taiga what TD of Thor Ragnarok and
Marvel Fame playing an alien app
developer named glooty we don't know
what the title of this episode is and we
don't know which episode it actually
comes from so this might not be from
season 4 episode 1 because the last time
they showed off a clip at Comic Con
during 2017 it was actually from episode
6 with them completely freaking out in
and out morty twenty-minute adventure so
this could actually be from later in the
run but they did confirm that there
would be 10 episodes in season 4 but the
clip seems very reminiscent of a needful
things type of episode with the devil
like be careful what you wish for
because glooty here has this tattoo
warning on his forehead do not develop
my app like you should not do this thing
because something terrible will happen
and maybe stupid jerry takes it as a
challenge because it sounds like it's
either his app or is his and Morty's app
like morty is in on the stupidity -
because morty clearly has no idea how
apps work and how the app store works
because he's just shaking him make it
how it works
that's not how apps work but its launch
day and it seems like it's a dating app
that they've developed because you look
at their whiteboard and it just has all
these apps that sound like ripoffs of
tinder ooh la love cupid er and love
finders it seems like that's the name of
the actual app because they have a
circle saying best idea but he just
starts taunting jerry and it seems like
he's threatening him with alien invasion
like who the mothership is coming but
the twist is is that the ominous beeping
is just an ominous beeping app so it
sounds like wherever this alien comes
from he doesn't have quite as much power
to back up the threats that he's
throwing
them but it kind of reminds me of that
Simpsons episode where they gave Homer
the opportunity to design a new car and
it wound up being the worst car in the
history of the world completely ruining
his brothers company like Jerry has the
opportunity with Morty to develop this
cool new app and it winds up being the
worst thing ever with terrible
consequences which is probably why
they're trying to take it down so fast
like oh my god we have to take this down
because something terrible is going to
happen the way Morty's getting super
violent in this to remind you a little
bit of how he was acting during Morty's
mind blowers he's slowly starting to act
a little bit more like Rick he's almost
come full circle because he starts out
being really timid then he gets more
assertive then he starts to go against
Rick by the beginning of season 3 and
then sort of comes back around on him by
the end like oh no we need Rick and he
searched to act more like him maybe
without realizing it because the whole
idea of season four is that the family
power dynamic is returning to something
more akin to what it was during season
two where Rick seems like he's not
dominating the family quite as much but
then you have situations like this where
Morty seems like he's starting to go
full Rick like I said though there are
10 episodes in season 4 and in that
comic-con clip Dan Harmon clearly says
that they've already started working on
season 5 episodes so they did a big
interview where they revealed a whole
bunch more details about what's going on
they said that even though there's only
10 episodes during season 4 they said
there's a way that they structured their
deal is is that they can deliver as many
episodes as they want at a time so if
they get ahead of schedule there might
be future seasons with more than 10
episodes per season but the bare minimum
is 10 episodes per season so either
it'll be 10 or it'll be more than 10
when we get to season 5 and because of
some things that they change behind the
scenes with the way they make the
episodes as Dan Harmon implies during
this comic-con clip they now have the
job security in the system to keep the
trains running on time so we won't have
to wait more than a year to get season 5
they could wind up dropping it before
November 2020 like we could get it
during the summer but I'm just assuming
it's on a yearly schedule to be fairly
predictable so just assume November
release dates from here on out but for
all of you wondering if they were
planning on canceling Rick and Morty or
ending it after their 70 episode renewal
because that's a lot of episodes they
said that they don't plan on ending the
show anytime soon Justin roiland
said in this interview that he feels
like the show could go for 20 more years
just like the Simpsons because the
characters don't really age in real time
like traditional drama characters so
they plan on making the show as long as
they have new stories they want to tell
so don't be surprised if they make it to
150 or even 200 episodes but that's like
so far down the road that obviously
they're not going to know about that
till they finish this first 70 episode
block you may have seen all the pictures
Dan Harmon and the writers have been
posting from the writers room what they
changed behind the scenes is that they
brought in a more administrative
showrunner so the Dan Harmon could
offload a lot of the non-creative work
to this other person and this other
person is sort of the traffic cop that
keeps the trains running on time when
Dan Harmon goes on a big white tangent
but the funny thing is is that Dan
Harmon was joking on Harmon town about
just completely messing around in the
writers room and is like well this other
guy that they brought in to be
showrunner can't fire me because I'm the
creator I'm in charge of everybody but
the way he talks about their creative
process just makes it sound like now
he's spending all of his time thinking
about stories and writing scripts and
this other showrunner guy is just doing
everything else that he doesn't want to
do they did say that you would
absolutely have to re-watch season three
before you start watching season four
and confirmed that there would be
serialized elements of the mythology
continuing in season four mixed with the
one-off episodes same way they did it
during season three which I feel like
confirms is a continuation of the evil
Morty storyline The Citadel of Rick's
and based on some of the other previews
that they drop like the crock you bought
picture where it seems like they go to
Crocky BOTS home planet seems like The
Vindicator storyline is continuing to in
some sense or at least they're exploring
some of this larger of indicators
mythology because that episode sets up
all this crazy backstory like they've
been on all these adventures that we've
never seen actually know Morty we've
actually done a couple other adventures
without you because we didn't want to
have Rick along we felt like he was a
bad mix for the group they didn't say
exactly which other stories are going to
be coming back they did reference
bringing back a lot of characters from
previous seasons but this is that that's
always on the table they just try to
find the right story to bring certain
things back like mr. poopy butthole
popping up all the time
see you for season four in like a really
long time I might even have a big white
Santa Claus beard the really big guest
stars that they announced include Taika
Waititi who's playing this glooty alien
app developer character during the
season 4 trailer that you just saw sam
neill of Jurassic Park Fame they didn't
say exactly what he's doing or what he's
playing or if it's going to be another
Jurassic Park reference because they
kind of already did that with John
Oliver's character they also have Paul
Giamatti playing a character and
Kathleen Turner but obviously they
didn't say who's they're playing or what
their characters are like they did say
that they're also still planning on
doing a Kanye West episode but it won't
be till season 5 they actually talked
quite a bit about that whole Kanye
business from last year so if you don't
know what the Kanye business is about
last year Kanye West tweeted out the
most celebratory fan tweet that you
could possibly do about Rick and Morty
season three justin roiland naturally
saw it he makes a lot of music and funny
parody songs for Rick and Morty episodes
that they then released later Kanye
West's teasing that he wants to be a
part of Rick and Morty so it's like why
don't you just get together and figure
out an episode to do together recently
they said that they did have very
earnest talks with Kanye West about
getting together to figure out an
episode in a character for him to play
and something to do together during a
Rick and Morty episode but because of
what they've been doing working on
getting season four out and because of
Kanye West's schedule they haven't been
able to actually sit down to figure out
what that episode is going to be so the
Kanye West episode won't be at least til
season 5 but they do plan on doing it at
some point I would expect it to be a mix
of him playing an actual character but
also singing a song or writing a new
song for the episode just because that's
such a very Rick and Morty thing to do
get schwifty with Kanye West Moon Man
sequel any of the best songs of Rick and
Morty that you could possibly think of
so I'm just really excited to see what
ends up coming of that if they announce
any other big things during their panel
or they drop any more animatics or
teasers or anything like that I'll
totally do videos for it but there'll be
more Comic Con trailers dropping later
today I'm also working on a Witcher
comic
trailer that should post in a little
while and then obviously all the big
Marvel and DC stuff happening on
Saturday so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you see all the
videos when I post them it's just a
reminder that Rick and Morty season four
is gonna premiere in November but you do
have an opportunity to see season four
episode one before everyone else you can
click here to learn about that and you
can click here for all my spider-man far
from home post credits scene Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]